matching a season-long 7 game win streak  as OKC pummels the heat here in South  Florida 118 102 and you see Paul George  exchanging jerseys he's gonna get a good  one these Miami Vice jerseys are some of  the best in the NBA he's gonna get  Dwyane Wade the future hall-of-famer and  his 16th season one all-star for another  and call George now gets to take a  picture with one of the NBA's greats  from this generation now that is a great  picture right there folks that is a  great picture for the ages it's two guys  know each other known each other for a  long time and we know that it's curtain  time for Dwyane Wade and what a  beautiful moment as those two embrace